huh
[Music]
water
i need water
water
what
what
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is our salah workshop and we are
going to run out of stock if you don't
act soon i know what you're wondering
out of stock let me explain once we our
target to pay for the prayer mats and
the workshop we don't need any more
donation which means you won't be able
to sponsor someone and reap that reward
every single time they pray some of
these people have taken shahadah with us
we teach them how to do with learn the
actions of salah we help them memorize
the surah fatiha in arabic providing
them with a prayer path but most
importantly spending quality time
mentoring them imagine every time they
pray it will be on your scale every
single salah for the rest of their life
not only that when they teach their kids
and their grandkids guess who scared
it's on yours oh and before i forget
we're also launching our online prayer
course which will push the 700 000 plus
people online and guess what it will be
available for people to watch around the
world imagine new muslims learning salah
from around the world from japan to
mexico and you will never know that was
all because of you until the day of
judgement we're looking for just 1 000
people to give 100 pounds each to allow
us to teach 10 000 people how to pray
their salah will allah choose you to be
one of them click the button or the link
and donate now